this is the video in question first
shared with K1 via the next door app
here's a story this is from uh Texas
over the last couple days uh and there
is a young teenage kid I will make no
note of his race you can decide if you
think there's a racial element to to
this yourself uh who went up to a
complete stranger at a park and slugged
him you're going to see the video uh
this is from Cypress Texas and watch how
the media frames the story this kid who
attacked this man
for no particular reason watch the the
suck job that the media did 19-year-old
Alfred Lewis spoke with me about how he
feels about it now you know I just made
a mistake and everybody makes mistakes
this is the video in question first
shared with K1 via the nextd door app in
it you can clearly see Lewis striking a
man in the head from behind before he
turns around in shock I know like from
the video all you see is like the bad
part about it but um what people didn't
see was that I shook his hand after and
how I had gave the man a hug that is
something we cannot verify nor can we
confirm that another man seen in the
video getting punched and grabbed later
left on good terms according to Lewis I
really didn't expect for it to just go
so left you
know I have a lot of questions about
that um so he beats the crap basically
could have killed that guy like a slug
like that from the back of your head
when you're not expecting absolutely
could kill you absolutely could put you
in a coma right uh but now the media
does this job on him well what did he
think about he didn't realize it was
going to go so crazy the video is only
showing you a portion he hugged the guy
so he claims there's no video evidence
of the of the uh of the hug but the
reason I'm showing you this that is a
micro version of something that has
burst forth throughout Society if you
had the race situation backwards on that
right so let's just say I don't know
that kid looked like he was what 15 16
years old 15 16y old white kid ran up
behind a random black dude and slugged
him like that we would have riots in the
street Barack Obama would be saying that
guy looked like my son or my cousin but
when it doesn't fit the narrative we
suddenly humanize the people and we we
neutralize the vice and crime that they
are causing all over our cities and
towns